mon père m'a toujours dit Cécile fait
attention quand on insulte ou quand on
te crache dessus c'est pas Cécile qu'on
insulte c'est pas sur toi qu'on crache
c'est sur l'uniforme c'est sur le
policier
et nous accueillons notre invité du
samedi 20h ce soir Cécile la couture
banquière bonsoir bonsoir à tous Alors
Cécile vous êtes fonctionnaire de police
vous n'êtes pas juste habillé en flic
pour faire fantasmer erikiotti
non non
en tout cas merci d'être là c'est rare
d'avoir un témoignage d'un fonctionnaire
de police en uniforme qui vient parler
de sa profession à télévision je crois
que c'est c'est merci d'être là en tous
les cas merci de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
Cécile rebonsoir d'abord je voulais
savoir pourquoi vous avez un brassard
mais en fait comme vous le savez
peut-être on a un de nos collègues
Nicolas qui est décédé en fonction à
Melun ces derniers jours il a sauté dans
la scène pour sauver un monsieur qui
s'était lui-même jeté dans la scène et
il est décédé et c'est en l'honneur de
mes autres collègues j'en sais je
Patrice qui sont décédés également cette
année alors vous êtes né en 1974 et dès
votre plus jeune âge vous baignez dans
une ambiance policière et pour cause
votre père est gardien de la paix oui
joli mot
à 5 ans vous piquez l'uniforme de votre
père et vous mimer des interventions
policières
vous êtes fier de votre père
jusqu'à l'entrée en 6e là vous commencez
par raconter qu'il est coiffeur quand
même oui oui parce que
être enfant de flics c'est pas évident
en fait ce qui vous donne le virus
effectivement c'est que vous adorez que
votre père vous raconte c'est ses nuits
policière ces enquêtes c'est ses courses
poursuites tout ça vous vous passionne
mais malgré votre échecobacs
vous attendez 26 ans pour passer le
concours qui vous permettra de devenir
gardien de la paix
oui en fait ça pas ça pas été une
vocation de suite alors vous allez à
l'école de police à Fos-sur-Mer alors
c'est à 700 km de chez vous ce qui fait
que vous faites 700 km tous les
dimanches après-midi pour y aller 700 km
tous les vendredis pour revenir c'est le
papa qui s'occupe de Clément qui donne
les biberons vous voyez pas grandir
votre enfant
je souhaite à personne ça quand vous
voyez votre petit bout de chou qui est
qui est dans son trotteur et qui voit
votre gros sac sur la table de la
cuisine et qui pleure que Momo
vous avez pas envie et j'ai vraiment
essuyé quelques larmes effectivement
tous les dimanches après-midi quand je
partais il s'accrochait quoi tout à fait
alors à la sortie de l'école vous êtes
nommé à Montgeron dans l'Essonne
c'est vrai qu'au début pour amadouer les
jeunes vous mettiez votre képi à
l'envers
alors là vous découvrez la violence au
quotidien toutes les choses qui
s'apprennent pas à l'école
déjà quand vous arrivez dans une cité
sensible on vous jette des pierres on
vous jette des briques
d'ailleurs c'est une des premières
choses que l'on apprend quand on rentre
dans une cité on regarde pas ces choses
sur on regarde toujours en haut parce
que le danger il vient souvent d'en haut
alors ça peut aller de l'oeuf jusqu'à la
machine à laver ou laver
et jamais de micro-ondes
mon les récupère dans ces
arrivez dans la cité en fait c'est
souvent les différents familiaux des
disputes de couple et là vous faites
insulter vous faites menacer vous faites
cracher dessus
oui oui c'est notre quotidien oui mon
père m'a toujours dit Cécile fait
attention quand on insulte ou quand on
te crache dessus c'est pas Cécile qu'on
insulte c'est pas sur toi qu'on crache
c'est sur l'uniforme c'est sur le
policier et j'essaie effectivement de
faire abstraction de ce genre de choses
mais c'est vraiment pas évident alors ça
vous dites c'était le bon temps parce
que aujourd'hui ce que vous redoutez le
plus c'est les tirs à balles réel quoi
mon plus peur tu as un flic c'est c'est
fini ça on a
ils n'ont pas peur de nous tirer dessus
alors qu'on est père mère de famille
n'ont pas peur de nous tuer vous savez
Thierry ce qu'on dit chez nous on dit
que
le policier qui a fait le meilleur
boulot dans sa journée celui qui rentre
entier chez lui le soir
et ça c'est clair parce que c'est tous
les jours Thierry c'est tous les jours
qu'on prend des cailloux j'ai un
collègue de la BAC qui vient me voir un
jour il me dit il avait son bébé dans
les bras et le collègue c'est une
armoire à glace vraiment le mec vous
vous dites il a peur de rien quoi il
avait son bébé dans les bras il était là
il le tenait il le touchait et il
l'embrassait d'un oignon de dire je suis
vivant et me disait Cécile tu t'imagines
hier soir il est passé à ça le pavé
Hassan ma tête il est passé le pavé et
il était là il touchait son bébé mais
quand vous voyez ça les gens s'imaginent
pas les gens s'imaginent pas on dit on
dit oui une voiture de police s'est fait
caillasser mais on s'imagine pas que
dedans il y a des flics il y a des pères
et des mères de famille à l'intérieur de
la de la voiture
donc on casse une voiture s'ils veulent
mais contre elle nous touche pas mais
comment vous expliquez qu'aujourd'hui on
est plus peur de tuer un flic quand même
grave quoi
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
dise je sais pas je peux pas vous
répondre j'en sais rien
alors vous connaissiez j'en sais je n'ai
rien policier assassiné par le commando
de l'ETA à Dammarie-les-Lys à 2 ans de
la retraite vous aviez bu dans sa tasse
quelques jours avant c'était sa tasse de
café fétiche et les collègues Pride
prête sa tasse de café c'est
impressionnant et quelques jours après
alors que j'étais en train de préparer à
manger à mes enfants je reçois un coup
de fil vite Cécile faut venir au
commissaire Dammarie il y a eu quelque
chose de dramatique
bien évidemment j'ai tout lâché je suis
parti et là j'ai vu mes collègues
effondrés mais effondré parce qu'on
avait tué Jean Serge j'en sais je qui
était vraiment
un élément important du commissariat de
Dammarie-les-Lys et quand on sait
ce qui s'est passé à ce moment-là
ce que mes collègues qui sont restés ont
vécu
et ce qu'on échange on leur a donné
je m'explique
mes collègues auraient pu se faire
massacrer
massacrer au même titre que j'en serre
il y a un mec qui a tiré dans le tas
j'en cherche j'ai pris une balle et une
petite fliquette qui a tenu en respect
indien des tueurs
qui sont allés chercher le corps de gens
serre pour lui prodiguer les premiers
soins qui devaient en même temps se
protéger des balles c'était des rafales
j'ai mon collègue là-bas une des balles
lui passait à la lui a frôlé lui a frôlé
et quand nous on a demandé à ce que au
moins les titulaires et le grade de
brigadier
pour être reconnu en tant que victime
que l'administration nous répond ah ils
ont pas été blessés ils ont pas le droit
à au gras de supérieur à dire c'est que
tout ça pour 1700 euros par mois
et une vie de couple qui fait naufrage
évidemment à cause des à cause des
horaires à cause de la violence que vous
rapportez à la maison parce qu'on peut
pas vivre ça toute la journée et le soir
voilà quand on rentre à la maison on
trimballe ça avec soi j'imagine on
essaie de faire abstraction mais il y a
des choses qui des fois sont tellement
lourdes moi en l'occurrence un jour
j'étais au plainte et je prenais une
plainte d'une jeune femme qui s'était
fait dégrader son véhicule
la jeune femme on discute et me dit
ouais toute façon moi c'est ma vie c'est
une vie de merde il m'arrive que que des
galères c'est la bon qu'est-ce qui vous
arrive et j'ai voulu je sentais qu'il y
avait quelque chose je sentais et au
bout d'un moment je lui dis mais vous
allez le sortir sortez-le ce que vous
avez elle
s'effondre littéralement elle me dit
j'ai été violée par mon frère pendant 11
ans
j'étais la deuxième personne à qui elle
parlait de ça
waouh vous prenez ça dans la tête il
faut d'accord
à se calmer racontez-moi donc toute une
psychologie à avoir bien évidemment et
elle me raconte et elle me raconte et ça
lui fait du bien et on se donne
rendez-vous le lendemain pour en
reparler peut-être déposer plainte si
elle le souhaite et moi je rentre chez
moi avec deux heures de retard il me
fait pourrir parce que j'ai deux heures
de retard et c'est ce jour-là que vous
décidez de quitter votre conjoint le
père de votre enfant parce que c'est
plus possible en fait
alors c'est pas facile non plus pour les
enfants il y a quelques années au moment
de Noël
votre enfant qui vous dit maman regarde
le papa sapin et le bébé sapin et vous
lui dites la maman sapin elle est où et
il vous répondent
qu'est-ce que je fais
deux choses l'une soit je privilégie le
boulot soit je privilégie la famille au
bout d'un moment il faut je crois qu'au
bout d'un moment il faut faire un choix
quand les enfants disent maman chez vous
c'est au père qui s'adresse j'ai une
petite fille d'un an et
en fait depuis une semaine elle appelle
son papa maman et
et puis il y a des suicide
la qu'en fait il y a 40 policiers en
France chaque année qui se suicide et
c'est vrai qu'avec l'arme de service
c'est facile mais moi je me suis
retrouvée un jour dans les vestiaires
avec mon arme dans la main à me dire
il suffit juste d'appuyer dessus et puis
ça ira mieux quoi
j'ai pas fait la hiérarchie il y a pas
beaucoup de reconnaissance de sa part
non ouh là là c'est je crois qu'on est
peut-être le seul métier où on est
obligé de justifier qu'on fait notre
métier
je m'explique
vous contrôlez un véhicule la personne
est au téléphone
vous verbalisez la personne parce que
c'est votre métier et la personne c'est
le copain ou la copine d'un tel de si de
ça qui connaît bien le commandant de si
de ça donc on va téléphoner au
commandant pour dire que le petit
brigadier ou petit gardien averbalisé et
là on va vous demander de faire un
rapport pour savoir pourquoi vous avez
verbalisé alors qu'il était au téléphone
et ça c'est pesant de devoir tout le
temps se justifier de faire notre boulot
ça c'est sûr même si personne ne nous
aime nous on l'aime ce métier
quoi de toute cette politique
sécuritaire qui est mise en place par
Nicolas Sarkozy ortefeu
estrosioti
nous recommencez pas le spectacle alors
qu'on a une expérience vécu réelle et
que j'espère que les spectateurs et les
téléspectateurs seront émus d'avoir
entendu madame que je respecte
infiniment
et je dois témoigner que je faisais
partie quand j'étais jeune des Français
qui disaient toujours du mal de la
police
seulement mon expérience professionnelle
m'a complètement changé pourquoi parce
que quand il y avait un pépin dans mon
amphi quand il y avait un malade quand
il y avait un
suicidée des collègues ils étaient
absents si j'appelais des médecins il
fallait les payer je n'avais pas les
moyens on appelait les flics et chaque
fois qu'on appelait les flics 1 ils
étaient là deux ils étaient là tout de
suite troisièmement ils étaient toujours
bien formés c'est-à-dire psychologue
intelligent généreux etc et tout d'un
coup je me suis aperçu que la République
c'était vous madame
un jour pour des raisons très
spécifiques que j'ai enfoncé la porte du
d'étudiante et je me suis aperçu qu'elle
s'était suicidé j'ai appelé la police et
le policier a dépendu la fille et je lui
ai dit mais vous avez un métier
extraordinaire elle m'a dit mais
monsieur des
suicidés que je dépends mais j'en
dépends deux ou trois par mois
par conséquent le respect que j'ai pour
votre métier est infini merci nous
connaissons des civilisations que nous
admirons beaucoup qui n'avaient pas de
police
par exemple la Grèce antique que nous
admirons pour sa philosophie pour ses
sciences pour son art etc il n'avait pas
de police et vous savez comment ça
marchait l'ordre public par dénonciation
c'est-à-dire par la haine réciproque que
ce données les voisins les uns envers
les autres et l'instauration
institutionnelle de la police a fait
cesser ses dénonciations et par
conséquent l'arrivée de la police a été
deuxièmement théoriquement et
historiquement l'advenu de la démocratie
voilà merci à tous en tous les cas et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu